[Music]
thank you
another snackable edition of the podcast
today Barry quarter Lord Taco who's
praying all of a sudden uh I'm just
excited for these snacks I love these
snacks you do love snacks for a man who
doesn't really enjoy food all that much
you do enjoy a snack
you gotta have a good snack yeah
favorite snack what is it
popcorn
uh sure popcorn popcorn and peanuts for
me oh come on Taco you have an opinion
about this don't just say yeah popcorn
I'll go with that
uh you know if I'm feeling fancy maybe
some Ritz crackers you know get the
cheese whiz get the upstairs yeah
how about you Brad favorite snack
nothing nothing be nothing will ever
beat a pretzel
you give me a regular pretzel glued
amount of salt you're not beating it
it's the easiest yes because you can
walk around you can like I like a food
that you can walk around with pop in and
you can like experience the world with
it you know you can't do that with like
a handful of chips what you get you know
there's crumbs you get the impression
that every pretzel never goes bad has a
shelf life of like a hundred years
well yeah yeah yeah I mean I I feel I
feel like aged pretzels are the better
way to go get a nice little softness on
them yeah you don't even need to heat
them up they just have that hard shell
on them like they're gonna be there
forever so yeah so like you like me hard
shell yeah a little salty yeah a little
salty yeah so this is a this is another
snackable edition of the uh the podcast
because another artist interview from
backstage at Bonnaroo who do you have uh
now guys backseat lovers oh good these
are my guys yeah so this happened
randomly because I found myself
um
I didn't even know it was happening to
be honest with you but I I had dinner in
New York with uh the manager I just
happened to be sat right across the the
table from him and I didn't even know
what he did for a living until the end
of the night because we were having such
a ball we literally were making each
other cry laughing at the table I loved
this dude so much and then at the end of
the night I'm like so yeah why are you
at this dinner he goes oh I I have camp
and I have backseat lovers and that's
when I just erupted because I love this
band I love this band I love Kilby girl
talk about a song that my format and and
and the stations inside my format have
just completely whiffed on I thought
that song was great it's Taylor Made for
the farm it's tailor-made for big open
wide spaces in the sun with with wind
coming across the field I love that band
and I I couldn't stop talking about him
and then I was like oh wait you're going
to Bonnaroo literally in two days let me
introduce shoot to Barry and taco and
that's when he decided like yeah let's
let's do the podcast with it I don't
know if you got to talk to him and hang
out at all but he's just a Dreamboat I
love him so much yeah I don't think we
are we met yeah we did meet
um
but they were terrific and we all went
to this show in in as a group I think
there were what oh good six or seven of
us in the in the Pantera and Kai yeah
you know uh Tara Kai Brian Stone you
Brian Sean Sean Stewart managed to get
in the pit which we'll talk about later
um but the uh what I liked about them
besides the show was they had sound
issues they were on the this tent they
were the they they had a delay 20
minutes or so uh which we talked about
you know before with Japanese breakfast
which did not go well these guys on the
other hand when they when they came out
man they came out on fire
um yeah yeah did they shorten their set
at all or did they go the full 45
minutes or so they might have cut a song
or two they got more time because it
delayed everything as we talked about
later the uh even the Super Jam was
delayed on that same tent so I don't
know what was going on there but uh it
was very I think I think that that tent
this tent is perennially late they
perennially have sound problems
um you know where we used to make fun of
the witch stage for not sounding very
good you know the witch is completely
transformed into one of the better
sounding stages and now you know now we
have to try and get somebody to
understand that this tent is its
struggles sometimes yeah I don't know
what happened but I I you know was
feeling bad for her but it was it was
forgotten as soon as uh and I want to
give their names because it didn't get
it when we're interviewing them but
Joshua Jonas KJ and juice juice is the
drummer I think it was Joshua came out
and look I want to be a juice yeah
that's a good name right that's a solid
Nick yeah it's a great name it is yeah
but Joshua and Juice locked eyes and it
started and it was it was pretty awesome
and then they rushed right back to talk
to us oh really yeah which was great and
they were so nice
um they're kind of funny again I'm
hoping it was Joshua that I'm I'm
getting right but uh
never heard of Bonnaroo before it was
until they were both he said he'd never
heard a Bonnaroo didn't know anything
about it stop I think that's the first
time we've ever gotten that answer right
where is he from yeah I think so I don't
know I was so stunned I couldn't I I
guess I wasn't thinking quickly wait so
which which member of the band said that
the singer lead singer
okay I'm gonna have to address this I'm
gonna have to Lodge a complaint I'm
gonna I'm texting him right now I don't
uh this is very confusing to me you know
because it's always one of our our go-to
questions is uh you know what do you
know about the festival how excited are
you to be here and you know what what
can it mean for your career and he's
like I'll be honest I've never heard of
it before wow
where am I again just I don't I was it
was
like I said I've never heard that answer
before I mean like had heard a
Lollapalooza or Coachella I didn't get
all the way into that and partly uh I'm
really kind of proud of the way this
sounds is because there was a band
playing on the witch stage 50 feet away
um and so they were they were great they
were very nice so of of the three that
you talked to Briston churches and
backseat lovers how many of them or
which ones of them stayed how many days
did they stay did they try to get some
of the festival in or they were all in
and out pretty quickly that's a good I
think Briston had to leave uh
ah
churches was hanging around a little bit
weren't they yeah yeah
but yeah Briston hung out a little bit
because I saw him oh yeah and so uh you
know walked up and said hey to him so
yeah asking for money trying to buy a
corn dog
I haven't brought this up give me a give
me do you guys have any cream musties
I did I didn't get something but I had
spicy pie
nobody had a cray musty in my honor how
dare you what kind of friends are you
people no I think I know Stone did uh I
think he went okay so I had I got to
count on Stone to get a great musty not
because I'm telling you this was a
different Brian Stone than what we're
used to he had a good weekend
he was happy he had a good weekend
so if you don't know what a cray musti
is it's obviously a vegetarian corn dog
with a lot amount of lots of a crazy
amount of mustard which is in one night
one very random night me and Nick Turner
coined the cray musty uh so it annoys
the hell out of our campsite that we
called him cray Masters but you know
yeah which is partly why when you
started talking about poutine I just
thought it was another one of your
made-up annoying words
and I for like two days I was like I'm
not I'm not asking I'm not asking
I'm not acknowledging this made up
stupid word you know you never blasted a
poochie
and then and then we walked over and uh
got one and I immediately fell in love
and and they haven't been back but that
was if you remember that was the walk
over when uh we walked by the this tent
and they were doing sound check by
playing uh bird noises
and that's when our friend Denson as we
walked by stopped and said whatever it
was I didn't know the uh Wisconsin
warbler is native to Tennessee
whatever bird I'm just making it up but
we took like two more steps and then
every one of us went what
stories
he was so impressed with himself that he
was like oh that is a um Norwegian
cockatoo that uh no it's just a [ __ ]
recording system I didn't know they were
native to Tennessee
he's the hunter in our group I think she
didn't know but yeah I'll never forget
that what's so funny is it
yeah God that was good yep all right
back seat lovers so you guys like the
show yeah they were terrific it's a good
band right yes oh yeah it was good rock
and roll show They Came Out Swinging and
uh and the crowd going kind of going
back you know the crowd was waiting and
patient and uh boy as soon as it started
they had the crowd it was all was
forgotten and forgiven and let's go it
was great yeah that's great all right
well good and uh uh but Adam and
everybody was good to you everybody's uh
yeah all right yeah yeah yeah I mean
like I said they literally came off
stage and walked right over to talk to
us uh came over to the media area and
and again we had uh I think we mentioned
Kai Kai wanted she loves him she wanted
to be our intern for that one and uh so
she got take some pictures and uh they
pose for some more pictures with Dad now
you can't say that out loud because I
think that you know we haven't paid her
so we might be going at some sort of
like you know child labor law here uh
and I need to be careful too because I
don't want to give too much away but but
access and stuff like that but uh uh-huh
all of a sudden we get we get some sort
of letter from the federal government
wondering what our intern program looks
like where's our eeo sheet all of a
sudden
thanks Barry yeah sorry I didn't say all
right let's do it uh the Dex baxi lovers
on the what podcast live from Bonnaroo
[Music]
foreign
hey everybody welcome back to the what
podcast I'm Barry corner with me is the
back street lover back seat I've been
doing that all day tell me I'm not the
only one that does that oh yeah backseat
lovers man I was just sitting here
saying don't do it don't do it don't do
it
I did it thank you guys for being here
first of all of course yeah
um saw your set had a little bit of a
late start but man you came out on fire
what were you guys thinking when you hit
that stage
quite honestly it was really stressful
right before we were all kind of
freaking out because a bunch of stuff
was going wrong but as soon as he got on
stage it just like kind of channeled
itself into
craziness an explosion yeah
it's okay yeah it was fun like it I
think once we got into it and started
playing
a little bit
how much did the crowd help I mean they
were they were chanting ready to go they
were ready and then when you came out it
seemed like let's just go right yeah
they were great it was a fantastic crowd
honestly it like
it's really hard to worry about
logistics and things like that going
wrong when there's a bunch of people
just like smiling and having fun and
like
I don't know sharing a beautiful
experience with music so
it's cool
I don't want to focus on it too much but
I I'm curious because I'm sure it
happens
what are you thinking backstage when
when you know it's like let's go we're
ready and the things aren't working I'll
ask you first
um I don't know yeah I I think we're
just kind of worrying about like what
what we're gonna do if like something
like I'll thinking of all the options of
like
what we can do if something is broken or
like something's gone wrong so it is
like really nerve-wracking but I think
um usually like once we get up there we
it feels like the nerves go away yeah I
think the at the end of the day we just
remind ourselves that we're just up
there to have fun and I think today
especially we kind of looked at each
other before like after everything was
going wrong we just gave each other a
big hug and we're like let's go do this
and it was fun
you're being awfully quiet is that what
were your thoughts yeah no it was I
think it those moments kind of Empower
us to make the most of what we have and
be in the moment as much as possible
thank you sir
for anybody that didn't see it what I
loved was you sort of came out
you made eye contact with him and said
let's jump up in the air and then it was
on
kind of been learning our way around
festivals this last year we hadn't
really done much touring until this year
and we've just been kind of
constantly on the road and learning what
it's like to go to a festival in the
different uh amazing Parts about it and
the challenges and stuff too but being
here today is really
really special I had a really fantastic
time and I think that we all like even
though it was like a tough show for us
like I don't know it felt really
worthwhile and um also after this we get
to go home for about a month so it feels
really good to kind of end on that note
and go get some time to be with our our
loved ones you know
around today and tomorrow and see some
shows today I think so yeah today
who are you gonna see it's a question
everybody asks at Bonnaroo who are you
gonna see
um let's see I'm really excited for
Billy's strings
uh he's a shredder
Mount Joy yeah Mount Joy
there's we always ask this because we're
here and it's a it's a a Bonnaroo type
of question but does this Festival mean
anything different or special to you
guys in any way
um
tell you the truth I don't I've never
really heard of it so we got on the bill
I for me it's kind of a special
experience because I used to well I kind
of still do but I used to watch a lot of
YouTube videos of Just Festival videos
and stuff and one of my favorite
um videos is one of cage the elephant's
live performances here at Bonnaroo
and so when I heard that we were playing
this uh Festival I was really stoked to
be on the same same place as them so
nice I know you played uh at least one
song new song that I got to hear before
we came over here to get set up when is
what's coming out what are you guys
working on when can fans start seeing
all this stuff
well we've been working
quite a lot on a new album and it's uh
it's coming very soon this year it'll be
releasing it
um I'm not sure what other details we
can okay relay but it is coming it's
coming it is coming
anything you want to mention that I
didn't ask you guys about
um
easy holding out you're holding outside
no nope I guess not no no thank you so
much yeah thank you thank you guys so
much especially you just came off stage
and come talk to us like this we
appreciate it very much of course yeah
all right thanks guys backseat lovers
great great set thank you guys thank you
foreign
there you go uh there's your snap you
know what this is not so much of a snack
these three uh Taco this was more like
um shareable plates you know you've gone
to a this was a
yeah this was this is the Tapas
restaurant we did Tapas today and not
just snacks yeah
yeah it was a lot of fun I enjoyed it
thoroughly I I think Taco did as well
those are all good oh yeah
good people good bands I did and uh
shout out yep shout out to Brooklyn from
robust because she was over the moon
that we were interviewing back seat
lovers she loves them and that was the
only selfie I took there was with the
one of the guys from the band I sent it
to her and oh wait a second so you're
telling me that you didn't have another
intern show up uh because apparently our
intern program is thriving right now uh
because Adam as we see fit
well uh we're taking applications right
I know we need to print out one of those
pictures of the big giant Keebler Elf
and I'll sign it and send it to her
yeah yeah
I'm sure she'll be thrilled just what
she wanted for this band shows the
backseat lovers here's a picture of
Barry yeah
the good news is what you always do is I
think on the end so you can cut it out
but by the way just can we just stop
this for a second had Brad just said oh
you love insert band here well here's a
picture of myself you guys would have
murdered me well come on now I threw in
the Keebler Elf bit it was uh it was a
little bit of self-deprecation which you
would not do oh come on
my handle is literally breadsticks well
that's a good point I'll give you that
all right anything else to get to before
we uh take some time off huh anything uh
no we got a couple more I still want to
do I still want to have Sean on all
right yeah yeah I've got a couple more
we got a couple give it a break you'll
enjoy it I I really want to hear Sean's
Adventures uh if we can if we can get
him out of bed or or wherever it is that
he was the other morning yeah because he
was scheduled to be on last time and he
overslept yeah well that's never
happened to us that's what we're calling
it overslept that's never not not in
this professional this is professional
grade all right well do we have record
yeah good question good
I'll talk to you guys later all right
see ya bye
[Music]
foreign
podcast Network